hello you know you gotta pay for that
right hey not okay we got ourselves an
x-men fan maybe a quarter of it happens
and not like this in the real world
people die Logan I don't want to talk
about it Logan
just stop be careful I need the girl
buckaroo
[Music]
[Applause]
no no no oh [ __ ]
this is what life looks like
people love each other home
you should take a moment
Celie
you still have time
[Music]
two days on the road only one meal and
hardly any sleep she's 11 I'm [ __ ]
night
hey youtubers it's Charlie new logan
trailer we gotta break this down who's
gonna be so awesome I love the fact that
he's actually reading some Chris
Claremont era x-men comics we'll talk
about that but there is a new round of
the Deadpool giveaway it's a $20
comiXology gift card all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
Wolverine related comment on this video
be sure to click that Bell to enable
alerts so that you don't miss anything
so the big thing in this trailer is the
introduction of Laura
x-23 from the comics who's a Wolverine
clone and you see like a lot of things
happening in this that seem to imply mr.
sinister stuff that's happening the
comics that he's holding up or Chris
Claremont I'm actually having trouble
pinpointing them but they just implies
savage lands which is all genetic
engineering mr. sinister type stuff so
it just blows your mind that he's
reading comic books one but it also
helps sort of pinpointed in the timeline
like they're implying that all these
adventures happen somebody wrote comics
in the real world about their adventures
and this is happening after that we know
a little bit about how she enters the
felt like the context for what's going
on here
so the villains that you're seeing here
are actually the Reavers the main
villains like their two main villains
here you see Richard II grant he's
playing doctor Xander rice who actually
debuted in the x-23 comic way way back
but the leader of the Reavers here is
played by Donald Pierce they're just a
group that's dedicated to the
destruction of the x-men so the way
they're explaining it Richard II grant
like a lot of people wondered if he was
going to be mr. sinister that's not who
he is he is somebody from the comics but
in the continuity in the comics he's the
son of someone who worked on the
original Weapon X program so you have to
imagine that during Days of Future past
they sort of fix the timeline but now
they're you know back to being really
old again and you have the Reavers who
have been hunting down and killing x-men
so based on the synopsis the Hugh
Jackman revealed a little while ago he's
been hiding out on the Mexican border
trying to help Professor X and then
along comes this little girl that he
learns about so he doesn't know anything
about her but then he sees that she's
basically a piece
of him like literally a piece of him
because she's a clone and he sort of
confronted with himself because she's
exactly like him so because this is the
last Wolverine movie there's sort of
this eulogy for his character sort of
sending him off we'll talk about that in
a second like the future of the actual
Wolverine character but it's meant to be
a goodbye for him is he sort of looks in
the mirror and is confronted with
himself in this young girl so everybody
that saw the first 40 minutes of the
movie said it was amazing it's not like
any x-men movie that you've seen before
in the same way that Deadpool wasn't
like an x-men movie that you've seen
before and there are some similarities
with the way they introduced the x-23
character if you remember at the
beginning of Deadpool they showed that
scene where he basically destroys
Strykers lab as he breaks out of their
version of the Weapon X program it's
sort of the same type of introduction
with the X 23 character which was also
kind of the same way that the Wolverine
character was introduced way back in the
original Weapon X program but remember
this is rated R so it's just so much
more hardcore so it is the most brutal
introduction of this awesome little girl
so it's gonna be so much fun but the
Reapers themselves do share a lot of
ties with the Hellfire Club so even
though this is sort of like a smaller
self-contained type of movie you'll be
seeing a lot of things that refer to
other parts of the x-men movies just
little bits but the tone is just like so
different that that's why they set this
off by itself that's why it feels like
such a different type of movie but I
love the introduction here like you have
no context you just see you know a
little girl in a gas station just
grabbing stuff because she's hungry
almost goes full Wolverine on the gas
station attendant till Logan walks in
and stops her short not okay kid
grab some cigars and on the way so this
seems like it's a little bit later in
the film because they do have like a
relatively linear progression where you
meet the x-23 character you understand
how she meets the Wolverine character
and then that sort of sets off their
relationship in the rest of the film but
if you've never read the x-men comics
essentially she has all the same powers
as Wolverine remember she's a genetic
clone it's just that she has two claws
in her hands instead of the three she
has one in her feet but I don't know if
they
in the movie or not that might be some
WTF surprise
but speaking of powers it seems like
because Professor X is in his 90s his
powers are waning to just like
Wolverines powers of regeneration are
slowly waning so even though Wolverine
is functionally immortal because of his
healing factor there have been at least
10 times in the comics that they have
killed him off through various means
sometimes it's using magic sometimes
it's another version of Wolverine nobody
knows how to kill Wolverine like another
version of Wolverine from the multiverse
or from a different point in the
timeline so Patrick Stewart I just love
that they let him be in this movie it's
perfect for the old man Logan motif
they're going for even though this isn't
literally old man Logan the comic-book
most WTF Wolverine story ever you should
definitely read it if you have a chance
but fair warning it's pretty crazy the
way they explain how the other x-men
died and because it's Marvel Comics it
involves all of the characters not just
the characters that Fox controls you get
the sense that he's been very reluctant
to fight for a long time but the arrival
of Laura x-23 gives him something to
fight for
so you get the crazy intense Hulk out
moment here where he just goes crazy on
everyone but it's so much more fun
watching her do it to like she jumps
over his back here you definitely see
what looks like the death of Professor X
so it looks like this is his grave that
they're standing over just sort of
eulogizing him and then a lot of people
are wondering if this scene here where
they don't show their faces but just you
know Wolverine all cut up sitting
against the tree might be the death of
Wolverine that could be the case but I
have a feeling that they're gonna end
this movie in a way that will bookend
the character without completely
throwing him in the fridge like they're
not gonna fridge the Wolverine character
there will always be x-men movies with a
Wolverine character in some form or
another
but I think because it's rated R they're
a little more free to be ambiguous about
the ending like maybe he's not coming
back maybe he's gonna be dead then they
would in like a pg-13 traditional
popcorn movie that you see during the
summer so why I'm totally on board for
these WTF comic book movies just as long
as it's in keeping with the tone of the
character like you could probably do a
raid at our Batman movie but I don't
feel
there's a version of a rated-r Superman
movie that just doesn't feel in keeping
with the tone of the character so I'm
expecting the main x-men films will stay
pg-13 but if they do more Wolverine
movies in the future if they reboot the
character or they do a Deadpool
crossover like Ryan Reynolds is trying
to get them to do that will definitely
be rated R but we got to talk about
x-23 in the future of the Wolverine
character so there's a creative reboot
happening at Fox right now what I feel
like they'll do is they'll just kind of
quietly keep the Wolverine character on
the shelf for a little bit and then
they'll recast a new actor that is
age-appropriate with the time period
that they're doing the x-men films and
so the next big x-men movie the rumor
Dark Phoenix movie is supposed to take
place during the 90s they would cast a
much younger version of Wolverine if he
was gonna cameo in that but there's
still a couple years away so it's all
speculation right now let me know what
you want them to do with the Wolverine
character assuming that Hugh Jackman
doesn't come back but I do think it's
totally possible that he would come back
for some Deadpool crossover even if he's
just playing himself like it's some
funny joke like he was a mask in the
first movie maybe they do an actual Hugh
Jackman cameo in the second movie so
they'll always be a lot of like Hugh
Jackman Ryan Reynolds Deadpool stuff
even if he's not playing Wolverine but
it looks awesome I'm so happy like I
know it seems like it's been a while but
things are just getting started now all
the comic book movies are gonna start
posting a whole bunch more trailers
you'll start seeing more footage from
everything that's coming in the next
couple of months especially now that the
Super Bowl is getting ready to happen so
if there's anything you guys want me to
do bonus videos for for the Logan
character or for x-23 or the x-men
movies or Deadpool just let me know in
the comments there's gonna be so much
awesome stuff happening this year it is
gonna be a great year for comic book
movies what's gonna happen next is I
have some Game of Thrones that I'll post
so just look out for that where you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
to learn what's going on with the new
spider-man movie and you can click here
to learn what's going on with Deadpool
thank you so much watching everybody but
iPod I'll see you guys tonight